i like this question can i ask one real
quick question yes it's from haha it's
sean
sona if conan was your assistant what
would you make him do oh my god
oh
well is it like is it he's my assistant
knowing that i've been his assistant
i think so let's say yeah today for some
reason conan loses
everything yeah his entire fortune and
then
he has to become your assistant oh my
first of all he would be a terrible
assistant
oh my god could you imagine why do you
why do you say that because he doesn't
know how to do anything okay
yes
i think that's part of it i think
because he's had somebody do so much of
the smaller things for so long that if
you're like right hey can you email like
this group of people this thing he'll be
like how do i see people yeah how do i
do this
he'd get to keep david hopping right so
that would be part of the deal
yeah i know i think he'd be terrible
assistant i think cause also i mean dude
how many bits can you hear your
assistant do before you fire them
oh yeah that's true no you'd pay for him
to go to australia
please just please
yes go as far away as possible yeah
yeah no wouldn't that be exhausting yeah
he would just
did he just be doing bits all the time i
couldn't handle it
his brain works a very specific way and
it's not
to be an assistant yeah he's kind of
doing the only thing he really probably
could be doing exactly like i can't
imagine him having other jobs
he
bristles at authority like no one i've
ever seen it's
immediate
i i think that's why some of his
funniest remotes are where
he's kind of put under someone else's
instructions and
yeah yeah so i
i think you probably would have some
issues with him
yes i think so too oh for sure yeah a
lot of insubordination me
[Laughter]
oh man it's so true